hello and welcome to this
video this is a
new blitz game let's see do we get a
dirty harry
no i really would like to get it on the
board
i wonder if i already beat this guy
maybe with it once yeah
my name oops sorry
e5 you get those
rosso limo and other lions quite often
but
i think i have a real account of people
on leeches that i already beat with the
dirty harry
and then they
don't repeat it and rather
play um something else okay so i'm happy
with this this looks like a
really nice
rui lopez type of position
but with g6 played um
nah okay really nice it's it's very okay
i'm not better or anything
okay opens up the a file that's a
normally quite usual thing to do
or quite normally quite usual no that is
really bad language
it's a useful
thing to do not a usual thing to do it's
also usual
but it's mostly useful okay anyway
i am going for f5 simply because i can
i'm not sure if it's good though it
could be a risky decision
yeah no risk no fun right
bishop c2 where and then
yeah i don't know this i don't really
think is too dangerous
get the knight over to the king's side
and um i'm ready to play d5 yeah
that is a that is a big pawn center
right
that would be nice not sure if it's
maybe a bit too exposed sometimes it's
better to not
advance all of your pawns because you
have to
defend this huge center but
we'll see what happens bishop d5 is a
bit surprising
i don't mind to play bishop b7
oh interesting is that good though
hmm okay there are c4 tricks
c4 pawn takes
interesting
um it's nothing special though
i want to compete
compete fight contest
the d5 square maybe with the capture and
then
queen on the seventh i have again the c4
move
but
this is playable like just do this
at the end i get b2 i don't know
okay let's play it
queen takes b5 is that a move i totally
overlooked it
okay
i'm not even sure that this is any good
honestly
yeah i got i have e4
the knight doesn't have good squares
queen queen b7 he can trade
yeah i can go e4 i mean that that must
that must be always enough
really i'm very active
knight coming to e5 and stuff like that
okay um how do i play rook f6
now as rook d7
didn't really calculate this i thought i
must be always fine here with
all the activity like
queen takes rook takes knight moves i
have knight e5 knight d3
things like that
does he really have an alternative to
the queen trade
i mean knight h2 it doesn't look right
knight h no
okay so simply trading is good
i can take on d2 also and then bishop c3
that would be of course equal
i think this is not enough
it's probably better than equal actually
but
i think this is not enough um
i should go for more here 93
is pretty annoying knight c4
he has a pretty awkward piece on h2
really
um knight d3
what is he doing there going for
something on the seventh
okay bishop c3 i can play or f4
right go f4
yeah i can take take one f2
oh e3 really okay
he has checks but e3 is close to a maid
i mean back rank mates or promotion
looks very dangerous for white
e2 to see checkmate me
don't see it
so i can promote immediately or play
rook d2
for rook d1
do this king h2
and that is a bit of a problem rook d
wonder and rook on the seventh
uh that could work actually
that could work for him ah that's awful
king h2 has to play that i think
no okay it goes for this
check it's just a check right
i could have taken the rook i'm such a
clown
i should take the rook of course
now it's this is
still work to do
but at least i'm on 10 seconds
so i'm not going to
just lose on time
check and made
almost ah sorry not a mate but this is
going to be a mate
oh he has to give up everything to
prevent it
okay um that was a bit nervy
at the end is that the right word
yeah unnerving i don't know yeah i think
i'm okay
if i get in f5 that should be okay
and then there was there were some
interesting spots here okay i completely
did not see knight g5 here
which is a very typical motif
i don't understand yet why this works
knight g4 okay
okay yeah this is not exactly trivial
okay that means my plan was a bit flawed
with f5 um this is not
critical then knight g5 does work again
i had a complete blind spot for that
i mean i'm aware of the idea but i i
never
figured that it could work here
okay this
that was normal and c4 is i know
debatable maybe if this is a good idea
i don't think it can be all that bad
rook
a6 and now of course rook f6 given by
the comp
i felt this is interesting just play
actively
this and this
that can never be bad really for for
black
and i think i'm rather better
after knight h2 the engine wants to play
bishop c1 this is um the kind of
move that is really difficult to
see for a human player those
intermediate moves or
sufficient zook yeah
this is clearly failing and with bishop
c1
you get this tempo to allow
knight d4 and this is really complicated
not surprised that the engine is
evaluating this as exactly zero
because you can imagine that i'm active
enough to compensate for a pawn
yeah okay went here and now
this is already i think looking pretty
attractive for black
i can already play i actually cannot
play that i just see it
i mentioned this idea but this is
bad anyway because he has a check here
yeah
so this is better nevertheless 95 is
good rook a1
93 it looks dangerous
and probably now has to be very
precisely handled by white take
here i thought rook takes looks very
natural to
make e3 more difficult
and now i went e3 but there is a draw
right rook d7
he took first
okay so rook d7 it seems that
if i go back then
what is the thing and then he takes and
plays rook e7
okay interesting
yeah i have exactly enough for a draw it
seems
i wonder when exactly it becomes
losing maybe here right no still a draw
rook d7 king h8
oh he's got knight f6
wow
that would have shocked me i'm pretty
sure
knight f6 wow going for the arabian mate
i cannot take it
and i probably have to do exactly what
the engine wants to do
promote
here and now i have to play with check
this is a this is a really cool sequence
and check and at the end i take this for
a draw okay
he cannot escape yeah if he goes here
then i can finally take because
rook e8 check i have rook g8
okay yeah i don't know
maybe i would have found it with 10
seconds because
simply nothing else i have to check here
and there's only the check
with e1 okay he went
there rook d2
knight e5 rook t1 king h2
and now i should take it ah okay
yeah of course i can i can just take
that is that is stupid right i can
simply take everything
yeah okay that was not
not good yeah
and now we can take him
and it seems
hold a draw here yeah as the engine
confirms
he's probably fast enough to get the
pawn there
and after knight f8 that's a that's
totally silly i can simply take the rook
i didn't see it with a couple of seconds
on the clock
i took him and uh now he can again he
can draw with the with the trade
yeah okay a bit some hectic decisions
but an interesting game
thanks a lot for watching